i was staring at her she was staring at
me then she wanted a bottle then she
started crying and then she pooped her
pants and that was father's day
as long as you're taking care of your
kids have as many let me know well no
yeah no true though i guess as long as
you carry kids have as many kids as you
want i made the
wonderful leap from one to three i take
my vacations at work
father's day was a little different for
me growing up i'm haitian so
father's day is at the end of june
instead of the middle so a lot of times
the commercial stopped running
and then we would forget and get our dad
something from like marshall's
so we figured get him a tie we went to a
chinese buffet or some type of buffet
that was close to the house
and that was father's day in a nutshell
i grew up with
my mom my brother and then i had a
step-dad who came in later
in my life but my dad wasn't around
father's day to me was always just kind
of like another day i hate to call it a
joke of a holiday
but that's kind of where it fell for me
because mother's day was so
important because for so long my mom was
my everything historically it was always
a last-minute gift or scribbled up card
or something to just quickly throw out
left or right and
to be perfectly frank it's not built
for children to honor their parents i
know now
as a father it is truly a day to enjoy
having kids i think things that got me
through father's day
and what would get me through it today
is just kind of realizing that also your
dad's a person your dad's a human
and like people make mistakes and
sometimes people are just bad people
i'm not saying that my dad was i'm not
saying that your dad is but
once you understand that people are just
humans and that we're all figuring it
out
it's easier to not forgive but it's
easier to understand mistakes people
make
black fatherhood to me is one of the
weightiest titles that you can wear
in america today i was looking for
advice
i taught to my family and their advice
was more of a scolding and less of like
a loving embrace
i talked to a couple of my friends and a
lot of them were like dang homie that's
crazy
so it was it was a bit of some
soul-searching i also see that there are
like systematic things
that affect black men that would cause
them to be absent or
turn to to drugs or turn to
gangs and others you know the prison
system there's so many
reasons a black dad is not around and
now that i'm an adult i get that but as
a kid
you just see like damn like why aren't
you here dude as we address uh
institutional racism and the effects of
those
policies over time and how they manifest
in instances like police murder
but i cannot actually let that corrupt
all of the opportunity and space for
these children to be able to look at
that
and reframe that conversation to move it
forward for
others in the world to be able to
reshape
blackness's identity not so much as a
cloak or some other kind of constraint
or obscurity but it's something that
they can wear as an
emblem being you is the best way to stop
a lot of that negativity because if if
people hear that
all single dads do x and then i just
keep showing up doing why
eventually it's going to be on you to
change your perception it's not going to
be on me anymore
and i think that that's something that
would free me of that pressure as
opposed to
succumbing to it i know people
definitely have like issues around
father's day because there's always the
tweets of like
my mom did blah blah blah i'm like i get
it um but like
talking about your mom on father's day
is the same way as being like
we need a straight pride parade during
pride like it's just like
it's like yes there are lots of single
mothers who step up
and do incredible jobs on father's day
at the same time there are
a lot of great dads there are a lot of
great black dads fatherhood for me is
trying to do it like my dad did for me
um even if he's not the biological he's
the guy i call dad today and i love you
wesley thank you very much happy
father's day to you
watching my brother be the dad we could
have had and should have had because
like just because you're not together
doesn't mean
you can't be a good dad and like
watching my brother
be that for his daughter has kind of
made me think of father's day in a
different way and i'm like oh wow there
really are a lot of
great dads in the world hi i'm john
norwood i am the proud father of
three beautiful children and a happy
wife
uh nina who is seven august and ivan who
are four
and from all of us my wife tula included
we wish you a happy
father's day my name is andrew i'm the
father of a beautiful seven-year-old
named lynne what's up blinn
i'd like to wish my dad monizers houston
happy father's day thank you
and i also like to give a shout out to
my best friends celine
jeremy mikell sean everybody else in mmz
i might have missed
happy father's day guys hi my name is
ryan i want to wish
happy father's day to my stepdad tian
and also to my brother cameron
mila make sure you wish your dad happy
father's day and also
happy father's day to anyone out there
watching uh it's gonna be a great one
[Music]
you